yeah
it's a cloudy oh I'm there in the valley
and the [ __ ] Garden of Good and Evil
[ __ ] how you doing uncle Joey
here it's Monday whatever the [ __ ] you
had last week I had a bad week haven't
been Friday my cappuccino was [ __ ] up
on front who gives a [ __ ] it's a whole
new week [ __ ] it's time to swing dick
and give our [ __ ] pregnancy tests you
understand me it's the real deal
Holyfield December 12th
if somebody's [ __ ] birthday today I
don't know who gives a [ __ ] it's your
birthday it's your lucky [ __ ] day you
understand me uncle Joey's here you got
the world by the balls you got reefer
who's gonna stop you it's [ __ ] Monday
the only one that could stop you is you
today you understand me hold on when I
take a little [ __ ] break you well
you're not straight from the [ __ ]
heart the podcast is up no need to worry
you're ready to rock and roll
we got tremendous weeds today we got
some treats from sunset Erica on the
Russians look at this [ __ ] the Armenians
the Russians whatever the [ __ ] they got
the we that that you understand the
hairdos go 50 yards from the [ __ ]
house people hit me up Oh go here go
there anything listen I gotta get on the
101 to get weed that a tweet that's a
[ __ ] mission I don't go on missions
for week I got the best weed at [ __ ]
walking distance from the crib here you
understand me besides that it's your
[ __ ] lucky day you got it all going
on you got all the [ __ ] answers now
you gotta go up lying [ __ ]
somebody's out there with your lunchbox
in your [ __ ] in their [ __ ] pocket and
you're sitting there yup get the [ __ ]
outta here in Europe it's the US of A
[ __ ]
all day [ __ ] long you understand me I
love Europe I want you to worry what's
in front of you you understand me you
want to be international guy but you
gotta worry about what's [ __ ] in
front of you that's the most important
thing I don't want to hear no [ __ ] yeah
huh get the [ __ ] out of here
Oh over here smoking the world's best
[ __ ] reefer and you want to put a
backpack on and climb up a hill what the
[ __ ] are you thinking it's always a
beautiful day when I get to smoke reefer
with my church mother [ __ ] family you
understand me
this is how we do it that's what they
can't figure out I've been telling you
this [ __ ] that they can't figure out the
strength we got the strength that isn't
reefer you understand me with smoke
going through a [ __ ] screen
teleporting you all over the [ __ ]
world understand that's what they can't
figure out we got this strength of 10
dead [ __ ] animals right now so we got
to keep this going they can't stop us
Joey what's with the chitty-chat he give
me a [ __ ] ear beat and nobody's
getting I all right all right already
let's go back of this [ __ ] here my grip
is a little [ __ ] up I musta [ __ ]
my finger to death you were [ __ ]
something your finger turns purple it's
[ __ ] up what it happens
ah I want to thank you and all the
support of the special I see so socially
unacceptable that's what I am socially
unacceptable [ __ ] these [ __ ] and they
can suck my dick who wants to be
socially acceptable anyway huh we love
him [ __ ] you you don't love nobody but
your [ __ ] self and that stupid
[ __ ] hat I love getting together with
your [ __ ] so because there's no
podcaster by tomorrow afternoon that's
it get said [ __ ] bad smoke out that
bad air and now you're ready for a new
[ __ ] adventure today cuz listen
life's about adventures nothing happens
on the couch you took it you think I
would have met [ __ ] Puerto Rican
Nelson on the couch you'd think I would
have met [ __ ] lorry jack on the couch
you'd think I would have met stinky
Charlie if I was in the couch I've
honest I've been a street dog since I
was a kid you gotta get out there you
gotta get out there say hello bang it
out see what the [ __ ] the sun's doing
you had to watch the [ __ ] Sun it was
you know watch that [ __ ] look at
today he's nowhere to be found but I'm
watching I know he's around but I'm on
these clouds somewhere you gotta get
have the [ __ ] house people you gotta
make it happen nothing happens on that
[ __ ] couch not happening
ain't no jobs online you gotta get out
there there's money online but you gotta
get out and then get back in and put
your hand through it and [ __ ] get
it's not nothing else get out there
[ __ ] up it's Monday today's the day
people plant and [ __ ] money like
seeds and meanwhile you're sitting
around there's no work out there that's
the [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself
go get a gun a ham and go do something
if you can't get it together today
you're not gonna start the week on a
Wednesday so get up smoke a joint wash
your [ __ ] get some iced tea say a
prayer for your [ __ ] enemies because
they're [ __ ] choking on ball juice
today you understand me and that's that
message I can't sit here all day with
you [ __ ] and play tittle-tattle
all we could do is have a little tape
top eh I'll get you tuned up and yarn
with the rest of your [ __ ] day how's
that one for you come sir
I love smoking these balls with you
this is family in the stand is we're
family [ __ ] dust we sit we discuss we
discussed the attack we get a little
high and we got there and executed and
that's it and that's that [ __ ]
everything else is background [ __ ]
music you want to be family you gotta be
hustling and [ __ ] all day long and if
this pans out it pans out what are you
gonna do and if it doesn't pan out who
gives a [ __ ] at least you tried
you follow me I'm gonna go for weed
right now if the cops pulled me over I
didn't get no weight but at least I
vowed to drive I'm stone to the gills
but you know what uncle Joey's always
got time for one more ball you people
are special and I'm saying you like the
rest of these [ __ ] mafia
what should we decide either we go with
the [ __ ] Godfather or we go with
Mickey Mouse
let's go with the Mickey Mouse it's a
[ __ ] Mickey Mouse type of day you
know the same mooska mickey mouse
done Uncle Joe is like Mickey Mouse this
is uncle Joey's [ __ ] Clubhouse do you
want to come in do you know the magic
words reefer [ __ ]
that's it and that's that you know you
[ __ ] on my life so yeah without
you I got dick
you understand me because of you guys I
wrote because of you guys I think you
guys motivate me keep doing what you're
[ __ ] doing you're gonna get an animal
out of me pretty [ __ ] soon you
understand me
so keep it up kind of stuff that you're
doing a great job you guys think I
motivate you you [ __ ] savages
motivate me cuz it makes me be that much
[ __ ] better cuz I know you're
watching and when I know you're watching
I got to give you the best I can so when
you're out there you go Joey Diaz is my
[ __ ] captain people don't know
it's this chameleon that can be you know
[ __ ] that buck I'm stone know anyway the
podcast is baby
see so is ready for you codename Joey
January 6 Kaluga casino are you kidding
me or what that Friday night right after
New Year's everybody's all what we're
gonna do BAM
Joey shows up up there by Sacramento
Kaluga casino January 6 which Steve
Simone coming off his [ __ ] CD a bet
that's how we do it kind of suckers
anyway I love you [ __ ] alright
I have a phenomenal day it's Monday
don't take no [ __ ] from nobody right
your golf eat your [ __ ] kale and
that's it I love you guys have a good
day stay black I'll see you later